dr g is right about one thing and it's a
big thing everyone at home if you're
listening i do all of this stuff that
he's talking about in terms of chemical
talks you will not find
nasty cleaner in my house all the
furniture is vetted i care about this
stuff really really deeply but let me
say this if i'm disconnected from nature
and if i'm very stressed out the
inflammation in my body goes sky high
forget about the what i've buried
emotionally i can only imagine what's
going on there doc but
if my stress is up here my inflammation
is up and it doesn't all that stuff is
just not enough so you really have to
focus on that stuff that i know it's
it's harder to focus on the stuff that
costs nothing that's the hard stuff
right it's easier to say let me go to
the store i can buy this product it's
tangible you can feel it you get it done
check it's much harder to figure out how
to get in touch with nature how to get
your time in the sunshine how to like
work on your mindset but if you don't do
that stuff
nothing else will matter truthfully in
my experience that's just the way it
works you got to do the hard stuff